CHRIS BROADFOOT: So,
hi, everyone.
Welcome to a Google Maps
Developers' Hangout.
We're live from the
Sydney studio.
And this week we have Paul
Saxman joining us from
Mountain View, isn't he?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, this is kind of a rare
occasion for me to be down in
Sydney, but it's a lot of fun.
The winter down here is
not so bad, is it?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
it's lovely.
PAUL SAXMAN: I think the summer
in Mountain View has
been about the same as
the winter down here.
So looking forward to coming
down in the summer.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: So we have a
few topics this week.
So the big one is, we're going
to cover some of the maps that
we really like.
And these are new ones that
we haven't necessarily
highlighted before, so we can
give you kind of a preview of
some of the things that we're
looking at recently.
And then, we have covering the
sources, places that you can
go for inspiration if you're
looking for maps to kind of
get some ideas from.
And these are other places
around the web where people
are actually highlighting apps
or map-based apps as well.
And last, actually I have
that around backwards.
We're going to talk about the
places to go for inspiration,
the maps that we like, and--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: How
we find them.
PAUL SAXMAN: How we find them.
There we go.
So with that.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so
we're going to start by,
Paul's going to screenshare.
So if I switch over there,
this is sort of how we
showcase some of the interesting
maps that we find.
So maybe zoom in actually.
PAUL SAXMAN: Sure.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this is
the showcase on the Google
Developers website, so
developers.google.com/showcase.
And if you drop down the filter,
you can filter maps,
mashups, or you can look at any
of the other Google APIs.
So if we switch over to
geo, under Products.
PAUL SAXMAN: There we go.
No wait a minute.
There we are.
So there are 181 geo websites.
And the nice thing about
this too is it
allows multiple selection.
So as long as you select one
of the products, you can
actually narrow down.
So you can say I just want geo
apps that have travel or that
are crime-based.
That'd be interesting.
One other things that's really
nice about this too, if you
look on the right-hand side here
under the Other section,
you see the Street View API.
Another really important one is
custom tile, styled maps,
and Places API.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Let's look
at the Places API.
Let's see what we have there.
PAUL SAXMAN: So once you do your
filter, this is zoomed in
pretty heavily right now, so
you usually can see the
filters and the sites
at the same time.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, we're
missing my favorite Places API
app, the Map of the Dead.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, there happens
to be a request in to
get that added.
Why don't we go there now?
So I'd have to double
check and see.
We'll go there once we start
looking at some websites.
So this is where we actually
kind of highlight the
applications that
we really like.
So if you guys, A, if you're
looking for inspiration, this
is a great place to go.
But B, a lot of developers ask
us, how can we get in this
place or get in the showcase?
And kind of the short answer is
that if you build a great
app, something that kind of
map-centric is kind of what we
like to say.
If you look at a lot of these
websites that we'll feature
today, the map is the key
feature of the website.
The other thing is kind of
mashups using multiple
technologies on using the map
with, for example, the places
API or having a map with the
Street View or even Street
View with places.
I mean, that might
be interest.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And even
other non-Google APIs or
non-Google content
is great as well.
But yeah, definitely looking at
less commonly used features
but the more exciting ones--
like Styled Maps, for example,
is one of my favorites.
So if you've got a really nice
style that suits the content
of your website, then it sort
of creates more compelling
user interface and consequently
grabs our
attention whenever we see
a nice Styled Map.
Like the ones Paul's showing
now, it sort of just grabs us.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah and when you
look at these, like I was
saying before, they're really
kind of map-centric, the map
is kind of a key component.
Not to say that we will only
feature applications or web
apps that put the map right
in the center, but--
Old Maps Online is
already in there.
That's great.
But yeah, this is--
So not only do you have to have
a really good app, but
you also have to let
us know about it.
So probably the easiest
way to do that is via
Google+, I'd say.
Join our Hangouts.
So this is kind of an
opportunity today, if we get
some people actually sharing
some of their favorite sites.
We'll maybe do this again, if
this is a popular thing.
We can also--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: We'll maybe
review some maps as well.
So if you have a map that you've
made recently, and you
want some advice or how to
improve it, then yeah I think
that might be another good thing
to have on the Hangouts.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, absolutely.
So join our Hangouts, let us
know what you're working on,
and/or reach out to Google+.
These are all great ways
to kind of get
your apps in scope.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we also
showcase apps on our Geo
Developer Blog via the Map of
the Week post, which I think
goes out on-- is it Friday?
PAUL SAXMAN: Uh, kind of
the middle of the week.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Mid-week, yup.
So if I switch over there.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, let me
zoom in this guy here.
So the Geo Developers Blog--
so blogspot.com, or
geodevelopers.blogspot.com--
lot of different information
here, hopefully you
guys have seen this.
But we talk about--
for example, here we're talking
about the Google
Places API developer challenge,
which is something
that we're running right now
to raise awareness of the
Google Places API and give
developers a chance to
contribute to their community.
But then we talk about a lot
of different things here.
For example, this is an entry on
the ad units, new ad unit.
So here's some--
Mano's--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: What does
he call it, Fab Friday?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yup.
So he covers basically stuff
that's going on over the week.
Here's my new thumbnail, if you
haven't checked that out.
Yeah, and then--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: There's me--
oh, and Marcelo.
There's an interview between
me and Marcelo, who's down
here joining us.
Marcelo's the tech lead
for the Places API.
PAUL SAXMAN: And we'll try to
have Marcelo on again for an
event in a week or two.
But if you scroll through here
or just search, eventually
you'll get to the Map
of the Weeks.
So every week, we try to post
something here, one of the
maps that we really like.
We'll put a little bit
of information here.
It's not always--
I think a couple weeks ago, we
did Runtastic, which is a
mobile app.
They did something really
innovative with
Google Earth on mobile.
So we thought it would be great
to highlight that app.
This one is actually the
Volkswagen Street View Quest,
another really interesting
site to check out.
Here's the Runtastic,
Runtastic PRO.
So yeah, another great place for
you to go for inspiration.
Read the blog.
It's not only just the Map
of the Week information.
We post a bunch of stuff on
there, good place to sift
through to find good sites.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So what's
your favorite site at the
moment, Paul?
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh!
So this is kind of an
oldie but goodie.
Let's see if I have the
tab open over here.
So this is gta4.net.
So actually I--
this map is actually in most of
the talks I give, when I'm
actually talking about
introducing the Maps API to
developers.
And the reason is there's
a bunch of really cool
technology in here.
So they're using
custom overlay.
This is their own map of the--
What is the--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Custom tiles.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, custom tiles.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I don't know
what's the world called.
What city?
PAUL SAXMAN: Liberty City.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Liberty
City, yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: So yeah.
So they made custom tiles for
Liberty City, for the
Liberty City map.
They have a bunch of
great markers.
Actually, I'll just zoom in.
Another great feature too, I
mean you don't have to just
look at the map embedded
in your site.
So in the center here
we have the map.
But on the right-hand side here
they have all kinds of
toggles, so you can show
different markers on the map.
They also did custom markers.
They did very custom
info windows.
So if you click on any
of these guys--
actually, this is a video.
That's kind of interesting.
Stunt jumps, oh that's because
we're looking at stunt jumps.
And the thing that always really
wows people is when you
grab the little peg man here.
What they did here is they put
custom Street View panoramas
for pretty much all
over Liberty City.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
That's amazing.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah usually--
I mean it's kind of a really,
really unique use of the
Street View API, the Street
View service.
So this must have been
a lot of work.
I really would love to figure
out how they did this,
actually get all this imagery.
But yeah, they basically drove
through all the streets.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I guess they
had a Street View car drive
through Liberty City.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, maybe.
That'd be interesting if you
could mod Grand Theft Auto and
make like a Google
Street View car.
I think it's a great--
it not only shows like a
custom map interface--
there we go, back to here.
Whoops.
There we go, I had to
click that guy.
Custom map interface, so they
have their own tiles.
They've done a really great
job with these markers.
The way they actually styled the
map makes it look like an
asset of their website.
It doesn't look like a Google
Map necessarily, besides the
attribution and maybe
these controls.
And then just the--
kind of to top it all
off-- the Street
View is really cool.
So what are you thinking,
Chris?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Well that's
definitely one map that's
grabbed my attention
in the past.
A recent favorite of mine--
actually, I showed it I think
three or four weeks ago--
was the internet map.
So I actually found this
one via Hacker News.
So just go over to the
Hacker News page.
PAUL SAXMAN: I closed it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: That's OK.
Well, let's have a look
at the site first.
So for example, if I'm
interested in how big
google.com is in comparison to
the rest of the web, I just
hit find google.com.
And there you can see related
sites as well.
So they have some sort of
graph of related sites.
So if I zoomed in, all the
way in, you can see that
google.com is related to g.co.
True.
So this is a really great
use of custom tiles.
So you've got this almost
infinitely zoom-able map.
I can go all the way into the
smallest sites of the web.
And so they've embedded the
labels into the tiles as well,
so that some of the labels hide
as it gets too small.
PAUL SAXMAN: And there's
something, too--
the color has some meaning
with this map, right?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I think it's
the country, like actual
geographic country.
So this is not a map in the
sense of a geographic--
as in sort of in relation to the
real world because you can
see that as we zoom out, we've
got sort of the biggest sites
around here.
And as we--
the US sites over there.
And then these are all the
Chinese sites in yellow.
PAUL SAXMAN: And then there's
some trick too
with kind of the--
like how they're packed, where
they're positioned.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So related
sites are near each other.
So we might--
as we zoom in here, you can see
appspot.com, which is a
Google domain.
And I'm guessing as we zoom
in, these might be sites
hosted on App Engine or
related to App Engine.
So--
PAUL SAXMAN: AppNexus.
--there's no real
way we can tell.
PAUL SAXMAN: I think if I hadn't
closed the Hacker News,
I think people put some
really good insights.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so he
also put up a really great
blog about how he
created the map.
This is some updates here.
And I think this is about
how it's architected.
So this is a really great post
to look at if you want to do
something similar, using
custom tiles.
He's just customized the map
completely, which I think is
really interesting.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So kind of with the
exception of the
controls, it doesn't even--
you can't even tell
it's a Google Map.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, exactly.
PAUL SAXMAN: You're not even
using the Google Maps API.
Yeah, I remember when
this one came out.
This was kind of a phenomenon.
I mean, it still is.
It's a really interesting
project.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So I can find
the Hacker News post.
This is not it.
So yeah, this is one way that
we find interesting maps.
I read Hacker News
occasionally.
So from time to time--
that's not it.
From time to time, an
interesting Maps API
site will come up.
Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
So yeah, yeah, Hacker News, I
think that's a really cool
place to go.
We have a bunch of
other sources.
These are the places that
we go to actually find
applications that we could
potentially feature or sponsor
in the blog.
Yeah, one to point
out, Pamela Fox.
I mean, she's a former Googler
and former Maps [INAUDIBLE]
right?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: And she continues
to carry on the torch.
I mean she posts some really,
really interesting information
on her blog about using
the Maps APIs
and building mashups.
I think this one's about using
actually the Places auto
complete, so you don't have to
have users actually fill in
their form fields, which
is really nice.
But it's kind of one thing--
also, nice to point out is if
you build a map, and you can
actually somehow contribute to
the community, that really
brings it to our attention
in a big way.
So for example, if you do the
footwork of publishing your
map, and then maybe if it's a
free service, you can publish
something about, well here's how
we did it or here's how we
implemented this particular
feature.
So kind of giving back to the
community, which is something
that we really appreciate.
And it's just a really, really
good way to kind of bring it
to our attention.
So a few other places that we
actually go to look for sites.
This is the Google Earth blog.
This is actually hosted by
a couple of Google Earth
enthusiasts.
And actually you can find more
about these guys in there
About page.
But they actually go through--
it's not just about
Google Earth.
They actually talk about quite a
bit of different Google Maps
technology and sites they
find appealing.
So I just want to give them
proper credit, if we go to the
About page, and Frank Taylor
and Mickey Mellen.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Frank has
another really interesting
blog called the Tahina
Expedition, which is a
document of him basically
sailing around the world.
And he uses Google Earth to
track his progress and add
photos to the Earth.
And it's really interesting, a
really great use of Google
Earth as well.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh yeah,
there we go.
That is a fancy looking ship.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So you can follow his progress
and his intended route.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, this is
kind of another really
interesting use of Google
Maps, right?
It's not a site necessarily
based around the map, like we
were talking about earlier.
But it's using it for your own
personal information or
information that you want to
capture in your website, which
is perfectly valid.
Its something that we definitely
see as a good use
of the APIs.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So my favorite
site for finding new
maps is the Google
Maps Mania blog.
And so this was started
by Mike Pegg, who
now works at Google.
But it's still updated
very, very often.
Actually, you can see a cross
post from our developer blog
about the new ad formats.
So some news is posted up, but
there's also some really
awesome apps that Keir finds.
PAUL SAXMAN: "Connect with
musicians on Google Maps."
That sounds pretty cool.
Yeah so a lot of times I think
that the community can
actually find and aggregate
these faster than we can.
Oh, yeah.
This was actually one of the
ones that I was going to call
out, Blocky, kind
of a fun one.
Yeah, so these guys--
it's Mike and the current
owner is--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Keir Clarke.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yup.
So they find just pretty
amazing stuff.
And so this is definitely
a site worth watching.
So what else have we got?
Oh and another one, so this is
actually Carlos, our developer
marketing lead for the
Google Maps product.
He pointed out the programmable
web as another
source for digging these up.
And I've used programmable web
quite a bit before, but I
never really kind of put
two and two together.
So yeah, just if you go to the
API directory, you can sort it
by popularity.
And Google Maps pops up
right on the top for--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I think you can
add your own site to here,
to this site.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, a lot of
great information here, not
just about sites that
are using the API.
But you can see here
there's how-tos.
It's a great way to connect
with other developers.
There's 7,000 APIs
sponsored here.
I mean, we're only
looking at one.
Google Maps apparently has
about 2,000 plus mashups.
So I come-- oh, there's
360s, 360Cities.
I come here once in a while for
inspiration, just to kind
of see what's going on.
And I don't know, another really
great site to just dig
around and with, explore maps.
So we have a bunch of other maps
I guess we pulled out.
Maybe I'll highlight one
more and then we can--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Sounds good.
PAUL SAXMAN: --call it a day.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Let's take
a look at Map of the Dead.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh yeah!
CHRIS BROADFOOT: That's
a favorite one.
PAUL SAXMAN: I forget about
Map of the Dead.
Yeah, we highlighted that as one
of our Maps of the Week.
For some reason it didn't make
it into our showcase.
But like I said--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hey Marcelo, do
you have any favorite map?
PAUL SAXMAN: Whoops.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: You might
have to unmute.
MARCELO CAMELO: I would say Map
of the Dead, definitely.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
We're on the same page.
MARCELO CAMELO: [INAUDIBLE]
the Place API.
PAUL SAXMAN: I think we all like
it just because it is a
good Google technology mashup.
I mean it's not just the map
that they've done a really
great job styling it.
But also they're using the
Places API to actually--
in a really unique way, right?
I mean they've built a zombie
apocalypse map, using real
place information.
But kind of using it in the
context of zombie apocalypse.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: They have
this awesome map style as
well, highlighting
the danger zones.
So we start to zoom in, we get
an idea of important venues
that you might need during
the zombie apocalypse--
so gun stores, grocery
stores, doctors.
And then you can sort
of select them or--
I think, oh, you can't filter.
Yes, just a handy reference.
PAUL SAXMAN: I think the game
is in the works, right?
So this is just the exploratory
map, and then
they're going to launch a
complete game around this at
some point.
But--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Coming
this summer.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, I know.
I've been waiting for it.
[LAUGHING]
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, so it's--
I guess the thing that I find
really appealing about it is
again, the map is really part of
their website in a big way.
And it's mostly the style.
It fits their entire theme.
It really feels like
a map of the dead,
just because they've--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And so we
actually found out about this
site because there was
such a traffic surge.
I think it was linked
off a super--
maybe in the New York Times
or something like that.
So it got a huge hit of traffic,
and subsequently
Places API was--
traffic had a noticeable bump.
So we went to find
out what it was.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, I guess that's another
way we can find websites.
But that's kind of like,
unfortunately, after the fact.
I mean we discover them after
they've hit the popularity.
So we'd love--
if anybody wants to share maps,
like I said, several
venues you can--
Google+, come join
these Hangouts.
With that, actually, we'll make
one quick check and see
if we had anybody post any maps
that they wanted to share
because we'd love to--
here's Historypin, another
one we were going
to highlight today.
But definitely should--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Was there
a question on the Google
Moderator that we
should look at?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, let's
go take a look at that.
Let me go check the Developers
Live site.
[HUMMING]
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, I've got
someone wanting to join.
So let me add--
circle--
so if you'd like to join,
add us to your circles
and post on our feed.
And we can go and add you to
our circle so you can join.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yup, that was a
slight oversight when I posted
the original.
We're doing a Hangout
on air, so--
when you do actually invite.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So
[? Mina Minakshi, ?]
if you'd like to join.
OK, so--
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, no, we
didn't have any posts.
I mean this is one actually
I posted myself.
We've already highlighted it
I think in the showcase.
It was the Old Maps Online.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Great.
PAUL SAXMAN: So I think
this site's--
I'd say it's pretty ubiquitous
at this point.
As part of the David--
well actually, other
way around.
So the David Rumsey Map
Collection is actually one of
the collections actually
featured in this site.
You can actually browse
around the site,
browse around the map.
Or you can actually
search the map.
You can constrain by year.
And as you're actually searching
the map, it's
actually bringing up historical
maps related to
what's in your view port.
So it's really cool.
I mean it's really interesting
because it's new technology
and old technology.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: They have this
cool map overlay as well,
these sort of grid lines.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, it
is really amazing.
I was kind of curious how they
put this together because
their Google Maps implementation
looks like a
historical map as well, which
is pretty amazing.
Yeah they have the
meridian lines.
And yeah.
So you see as we zoom in
here, it's actually
going to pick up--
I think it's too close--
pick up new areas for
historical maps.
And in the right-hand side here
it actually shows where
the map fits in.
So I can click on this guy--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It loads
the map up, right?
Yeah, there we go.
PAUL SAXMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
view this map.
It actually takes you out to a
place where you can explore
the map by itself.
So yeah.
It's a great way to discover
these historical maps.
But it's also a really nice,
clean implementation of the
Google Maps API as well.
But yeah, like I said,
this is one of the
sites in our showcase.
Definitely worth checking out
not only if you're kind of a
historical map enthusiast, but
also if you want to get
another feel for different ways
you can style maps or
integrate maps into
your website.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So that's it for me.
I mean I have a few in here--
But--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh,
that's one of mine.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's one you want
to talk about real quick?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, it's
not a Google Map,
but it's quite fun.
It's a wind map.
So I think it shows up to
date wind in the US.
I think I found this through
Twitter, there was just some
people talking about it.
Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
I mean it's fully zoom-able.
It's fully dynamic as well.
I think they're-- whether
they're pulling
information from the--
it's actually live
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BROADFOOT: USGS,
something like that.
PAUL SAXMAN: So, "Read more
about wind and wind power."
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
It doesn't say.
PAUL SAXMAN: So I think it's
more designed as kind of an
artistic rendition than actually
an analytical tool.
But actually you can see the
hurricane down here, which is
pretty amazing.
Yeah so not only is it
beautiful, but it's also
informative, which
is really neat.
And it is fully zoom-able.
Actually, I couldn't figure
out how to zoom out.
Oh no, it's on the left
here, un-zoom.
But yeah, as you zoom in--
you can keep zooming in, and
it keeps updating the
information.
So it looks like
it's actually--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Wow.
--updating the display.
Yeah that hurricane's looking
kind of hairy.
So thank god I'm not in New
Orleans at the moment.
MARCELO CAMELO: Well, the whole
map looks a bit hairy.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
PAUL SAXMAN: Good point.
PAUL SAXMAN: So yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK,
on that bombshell--
[LAUGHING]
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK, thanks
for joining us this week.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah so we'll
be up next week, Google
Developers Live back
in Mountain View.
Just to give you a preview, I
think we're going to talk
about crisis maps.
So I guess the wind map is
a good segue into that.
But we'll post the abstract on
Google+ and hope to see you
guys in about a week.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And
back to the Sydney
Office Hours in November.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yup.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cheers,
thanks for joining.